oh my God
good afternoon everyone uh welcome to
this extraordinary meeting of the
cabinet uh do we have any apologies for
absence and
apologies from councilor Pemberton
thank you Anne
do I have any discloses of Interest
I'll take that as a no
uh so moving on
uh item three environmental health and
Licensing restructure I believe this is
councilor Kettle councilor kettle
yeah thank you Mr chairman for that I'll
start again
um
environmental health as you know is very
important service we provide
um and it has been under review and I'm
delighted with the results that come out
I'd really like to thank Julie and her
team for what they've put together
um
and I recommend I'm not going to go
through the whole paper we've got many
other things to discuss I recommend the
proposals to cabinet
thank you councilor Capital are there
any questions or comments on the paper
member of members of cabinet
I'll take that as a resounding no so
there is a recommendation to Council on
page one that the council agrees to
seize provision of a directly provided
Pest Control service and the
recommendation to Cabinet subject to
council agreeing recommendation one
above the environmental health and
Licensing restructure outlining appendix
to be implemented can I have your
agreement please members of Cabinetry
thank you members of cabinet so moving
on
uh we have
revenue and capital budget
2023 24 to
2027-28 and this is councilor Harvey
thank you chairman
um following the cabinet's endorsement
of the revenue and capital budget for
the fourth coming year on the 16th of
January it's been the subject of
consultation with the citizens panel the
non-domestic rate payers and the osc's
task and finish group the outcomes of
these consultations have been set out in
the respective appendices one to three
to this paper
the citizens panel response generated 32
responses with a number taking the
opportunity to express their views on a
variety of topics 17 of the respondents
were supportive of the budget with only
four generally against it
the meeting with the non-domestic rate
payers panel was attended by only four
people where both the section 151
officer and the head of development made
presentations and answered questions
those present appreciated the council's
role in relation to non-domestic rates
was to administer the system rather than
to set the rates to be paid a further
report on this meeting has I Believe
been circulated separately
the proposed budget has also been the
subject of review and discussion at
three meetings of the osc budget task
and finish group whilst it's not the
role of the task and finish group to
approve the proposed budget it is the
group's role to come to a view as to
whether the proposed budget was
financially sound and capable of being
delivered
on both criteria the group came to the
view that this was indeed the case
it's worth mentioning that appendix 6
the medium-term financial strategy has
been amended and that this has been
circulated separately to the papers now
and now takes into account the
settlement figures confirmed by the
government and the collection fund has
been adjusted accordingly
the task and finish group also received
a number of alternative proposals
submitted by the liberal Democrat group
which was which are set out in paragraph
3.4 of appendix one
I'm sure members of the cabinet will now
wish to give each of these proposals
their serious consideration
it's proposed therefore that members of
the cabinet accept recommendations one
to five presented in the summary on page
13 of this paper
that the proposal set out in appendices
four five six and seven are approved and
at the council tax for a ban D property
be increased by five pounds the
equivalent of an increase of 3.2 percent
to be set at 159 pounds 12 Pence with
this proportion rate increase being
applied to the remaining property bans
thank you Mr chairman
thank you councilor Harvey uh do we have
any questions or comments from members
of cabinet
from what Mr Buckland has just told me
uh when it comes to the liberal Democrat
alternative 2324 budget proposals uh are
there any that we wish to support
councilor shenton
sorry I was surrounded by a Machinery
here
um the only one that uh of their
proposals that I would support would be
the
um 50 000 for planning for planning it's
it's entitled here increased planning
enforcement I would amend that to being
planning a regulatory which covers
um enforcement as well and that's the
only proposal that I would be
comfortable with
thank you go into the other ones and why
I'm not comfortable with the other ones
if you wish
do we need to go into that level of
detail Mr Brooklyn so chairman you
you've received the results of the
consultation that's consultation with
other elected members the public the
business rate pays form are the notes of
that have just been circulated it's now
for you to take on board any of the
comments that you feel necessary from
any of those pieces of conversation and
and either
effectively ignore them or choose to
accept any of them in your final
recommendations to Council on the on the
budget for next source so you're not
obliged to take them into account but
but it's part of the consideration of
your your budget proposals
councilor Parry
thank you chairman i i as the portfolio
holder for economic development I just
wanted to make some observations and
comment on the request for economic
support for 50 000 per year for two
years uh in respect of
um generating Grant funds
um
whilst type I whilst it's very important
for us to be generating
um additional Grant funds from bids I
think it's also equally important to
highlight that since 2017 we have
generated the council has generated
nearly 25 million pounds in various
grants and bids and this has been
achieved by either using the expertise
the in-house expertise or where
specialist expertise is required for a
specific Grant fund then we go out to
consultancy
um what can what in view of the level
and the complexity of some of these
grants and bids it's very important to
match the right grant
the right app you know person preparing
the grant bid rather than
um I'm not convinced that 50 000 would
would may bring in an officer but that
officer wouldn't necessarily uh it's
such a wide brief and such a a wide
spectrum of different grants and bids
um I think I would like to feel other
members of cabinet would would agree
with me that having generated nearly 25
million pounds of Grant bid monies over
the last five years our strategy is
working extremely well thank you
chairman I would tend to agree with that
councilor Perry councilor Barker do you
want to say anything on this particular
issue and then I bring in uh
counselor
shenton yes I just wanted to agree
completely with what councilor Perry
said but also to make the point that
using Specialists for the more
specialist grants is
not just standard procedure but very
very sensible because they're the ones
that are successful
I would tend to I would agree with our
councilor Barker the other thing I would
say is that at the moment uh funds from
central government are so scarce that
the realities if you looked at leveling
up round two only one in five of the
applications was successful and the
majority of those were in category 1 and
we're in category two
Council shenton
say thanks leader um just coming back to
the alternative proposals then
um
I thought I'd be handy if I just put
some meat on the bone if you like of why
I'm against these other proposals so
zero carbon fund 150 000 rural Village
Halls climate change initiative fifty
thousand and Rural building solar panels
fifty thousand
whilst not against these per se they
should have come through the climate
change panel not through the budget
process they they should have come
through that route they should have been
approved by the climate change panel
they would then be subject to
osc scrutiny who would then either
accept or reject them and then they
would come forward to cabinet and
presumably on to council at that point
in time so I think this is the wrong
Forum the wrong way to do this and it
ties the hands of the climate change
panel's budget without the climate
change panel having any say on this
at present and then we moved to 3.43
on page five and this is the service
reviews the 66 plus parking scheme uh
absolutely no we've been there before on
this we only have there are only two
councils that I'm aware of in anywhere
around this area which I think are
wyvern and and uh witchhaven and they're
100 ones 100 pounds 175 pounds I am
struggling to find anywhere that would a
offer this for 25 pounds b a to be quite
honest I am struggling to find councils
that offer this this particular kind of
permit we've been around the houses on
this one it's been debated it's been
approved I don't see that that should
waste any office's time again green
waste charges
um
I'm at a loss to understand why that's
come back again
um I mean we again it's been debated
it's uh it's accepted by over 90 percent
of all councils that we want to retain
the right to use this it's a certainly
over 75 percent take up across the local
authorities or collection authorities
there is no reason why and we're at the
the mid the low to mid end of green
waste charges there is no reason why we
should review this again
um I think that's uh that again we
shouldn't waste offices time on this one
medical waste collection and Disposal
needs
um my uh my good friend uh the councilor
Barker will be able to confirm that if
there's medical waste that is collected
by the NHS if it's if we're talking
about the more narrow issue of stoma
bags well they come with a bag generally
and they can then be put into that bag
and put into the into the the residual
waste stream there is no reason to
revisit this again we've debated this so
all three of these we have debated we've
had long conversations it would seem
pointless going around the houses on
this one all over again so I am
absolutely against 3 0.43 and the three
items there and other than the planning
enforcement which we which were relabel
as uh regulatory
and planning or planning and Regulatory
um I'm against the other items as I've
mentioned you make some exceedingly
powerful points count solution councilor
Fleming
thank you
um I'm not going to go through all the
all the things that Ian's just said or
very eloquently put
um but I have to support everything he
has said
um in view of the
the the the sort of green waste and
that's proved to be massively successful
goes on to be more and more successful
each time
um and so from that perspective I I
don't see why we should be reinvent
trying to reinvent the wheel on that and
um on these other three uh from a
climate change perspective
um I've only been doing the the this
I've been on the climate change panel
for two years but uh been on the uh as
portfolio holder and I've never had
anything come to me on any of these
topics so I just find it a strange one
that it's coming through the side door
of the am I saying the right thing the
side door of the the budget rather than
it coming face to face that climate
change and I think if it was going to
come there then it needs to come to
climate change so that it can be
processed in the correct way thank you
thank you councilor Fleming uh I think
you your use of the phrase side door is
probably exceedingly appropriate there
is a climate change panel there is a
process set up there is no reason
whatsoever why projects cannot come
through the climate change panel and be
dealt with through a proper thorough
process Council
I merely want to follow up slightly what
councilor shenton said about the medical
waste collection and Disposal needs I've
said it till I'm blue in the face that
the yellow bins are not ours they are
NHS bins if anybody needs assistance
with getting NHS bins sorted because
that is their problem then please do get
in touch with me and I will route you to
um locally to Swift otherwise most
medical needs can be used in can be put
in the general waste if that because you
know things like stoma bags as we've
said come with bags for them to be
disposed in so as I've said come to me
if you need a yellow bin
thank you councilor barcode councilor
Harvey I think thank you chairman um I
agree with everything that councilor
shenton said and just to put a final
nail in the coffin so to speak
um these three proposals that are
climate change related add up to 250 000
pounds they can easily be accommodated
in this year's budget for climate change
initiatives let alone next year's budget
so I can't see any reason why but put it
through a lack of money cannot be one of
the reasons why those three proposals
have not gone to the climate change
panel
thank you councilor Harvey so uh
the reality is then the recommendations
to Cabinet one and two on page 13 and
the recommendations to council uh three
four and five subject to the amendment
that we will
accept uh the increased planning and
Regulatory enforcement budget of 50 000
pounds
is that correct members of cabinet and
are all members of cabinet in agreement
with that
yes
when we had the recommendations through
or the proposals through from the
original scrutiny committee it was
suggested that the 50 000 pounds for
increased planning enforcement be funded
from the revenue funding from the
capital expenditure Reserve could we
also capture that that is the source of
financing for this
um additional Amendment to the budget
please
would you be happy with that uh
councilor Harvey and Mr Burrell
uh section 151 officer is happy I'm
happy
is this section 151 officer happy Mr bow
I'm happy
thank you so we are happy so with
after that are we happy with the
proposals and the recommendations as
amended
thank you members of cabinet so moving
on then we have the treasury management
strategy statement and annual investment
strategy once again councilor Harvey
thank you chairman please stay awake
um there's an annual requirement under
the guidance issued by the department
for leveling up housing in the
communities for councils to draw up and
approve an annual investment strategy
that meets the needs of the chartered
Institute of Public Finance and
accountancy's treasury management code
of practice
this council's proposed treasury
management strategy statement for the
fourth coming years is set out on pages
73 to 116 in appendix one
as our corresponding meeting last year
on the 7th of February 2022 I drew the
cabinet's attention to the fact that at
that time the bank of England had just
increased its base rate for the second
consecutive month to 0.5 percent
the first time increases had been
announced in consecutive months since
2004.
since then we've seen eight further
increases the most recent being
announced on the 1st of February where
bank rate now stands at four percent
on the one hand this demonstrates the
degree to which the bank is serious
about its policy objective to control
inflation this has consequences for
borrowing costs for both individuals and
those of the government itself on the
other hand as far as the council's
finances are concerned there's this
Prospect of a continuation in the rate
of investment returns as were generated
in 2022
for how long is a matter of conjecture
as section 2.3 of the paper outlines the
prospects are that during the next
financial year it's anticipated interest
rates will decline although by how much
and on what timetable remains a matter
of speculation
appendix 2 on pages 103 to 116 sets out
the proposed capital and investment
strategy for the period 2023-24 to 2627
this proposal provides the framework
within which it's intended the council
should make its capital and investment
decisions over the next five years
on the assumption that members of the
cabinet have familiarized themselves
with these papers all of them
and subject to any questions they may
have I ask that approval is given to
recommendations one to four are set out
in the summary on page 69.
thank you chairman
do we have any questions or issues from
members of cabinet
I'll take that as a no or members of
cabinet having read and digested the
papers thoroughly I am sure have there
been any questions would have asked them
so in that case can I have your approval
to the recommendations on page 69 uh
recommendations one through four please
members of cabinet
thank you members of camp
of the Prudential indicators and once
again this is councilor Harvey thank you
again Mr chairman in conjunction with
considering its budget for the
forthcoming year the council is required
by the super Prudential code to set
Prudential indicators that ensure that
its capital investment plans are
affordable prudent and sustainable
the paper under consideration sets out
the factors that the council through its
section 151 officer is required to take
into account when considering the
affordability in its particular
circumstances of its intended capital
expenditure over the period of the
medium-term financial strategy and the
affordability of the capital financing
requirement to which this intended
expenditure may give rise
members of cabinet will have noted that
paragraphs 1.5 to 1.7 taken together
outlined the borrowing intentions that
have been approved in principle by the
Council of up to 15.9 million pounds
referred to in paragraph 1.4
the basis upon which the Prudential
indicators have been proposed in this
paper is set out in paragraph 1.12
the paper goes on to demonstrate how
these principles have been applied in
relation to the council's projected
program of capital expenditure and the
resultant estimates of how they will be
financed as set out in paragraphs
2.6.1 and 2.6.2 to demonstrate their
affordability
the cabinet is therefore asked to
approve the recommendation set out on
page 117 that the proposed Prudential
indicators for the forthcoming year be
approved thank you chairman
cue councilor Harvey are there any
questions from members of cabinet
councilor shenton
you said that would great surprise and
it's just a a minor one 1.6
um section 1.6 on page 117
um
the 15.9 includes 4.5 million towards
the share of refuse Vehicles do if the
WDC as it says are not able to finance
therefore they're part of it do we
therefore need a greater
ability or uh to uh to deliver the
capital program in other words maybe 20
million rather than 15.9
just
could I ask the section 100 151 officer
today you can Mr Burrell thank you
councilor shenton the figures I was
presented do include that amount on the
assumption that we do need to borrow it
it has never left our accounts for the
capital program until such times as
we've secured loan funding for those
vehicles and as yet Warwick or
internally financing it and should they
not be able to to do that we will
internally Finance until interest rates
drop to a position where we can
economically borrow
happy councilor shenden so with that
members of cabinet are you happy with
the recommendation on page 117 uh that
the proposed Prudential indicators for
23 24 contained within this report we
approved
thanks cabinet so moving on
we have one issue of urging business uh
councilor Crump from overview and
scrutiny
thank you Mr chairman uh I'll try and be
in the spiritual in the meeting keep it
brief as possible
um
there's a paper that's just come around
today very very briefly
um it was to do with tree perhaps for
farmers
um
and the proposal is that the council
uses 30 000 pounds from the climate
change budget to promote and distribute
tree packs for Farmers The Proposal will
be supported thank you
to counselor Crump and I think this
indicates how well the climate change
panel through overview and scrutiny to
Cabinet is actually working uh can I
have your agreement to the
recommendation members of cabinet
thank you members of cabinet and with
that
meeting closed